uh so
one is brave new world by aldous huxley
um and it's
kind of incredible how prescient he was
about like
what this what what a brave new world
might be like right you know you kind of
see
genetic sorting in this book right where
there's like these alphas and epsilons
and
uh from like the earliest time of
society like they're starting like you
can kind of see it
in a slightly similar way today where
well one of the problems with society is
people are kind of
genetically sorting a little bit right
like there's much less
like most marriages right are between
people of similar kind of
um intellectual level or socioeconomic
status
more so these days than uh in the past
and you kind of see some effects of it
and stratifying society
and kind of he illustrated what what
that could be like in the extreme
different versions of it on social media
as well it's not just like marriages and
so on like
it's genetic sorting in terms of what
dawkins called memes
it's ideas right being put into these
bins
of these little echo chambers and so on
yeah i know so that's the book that's i
think a worthwhile read for everyone
i mean 1984 is good of course as well
like if you're talking about you know
dystopian novels of the future yeah it's
a slightly different view of the future
right
but i kind of like identify with the
world but more
uh you know speaking of uh
not a book but my favorite kind of uh
dystopian science fiction is a movie
called brazil which i don't know if
you've heard of
i've heard of and i know i need to watch
it but yeah because it's in
is is it in english you know it's an
english movie yeah
and it's a sort of like dystopian movie
of authoritarian incompetence right
it's like like uh nothing really works
very well
you know the system is creaky you know
but no one is kind of like willing to
challenge it you know
just things kind of amble along it kind
of strikes me as like
a very plausible future of like you know
um
what authoritarians it might look like
it's not like this you know
super efficient evil dictatorship of
1984 it's just kind of like this
badly functioning you know but
it's status quo so it just goes on yeah
that's uh
one funny thing that stands out to me is
in um
whether it's authoritarian dystopian
stuff or just basic like
you know if you look at the movie
contagion
it seems that in movies government is
almost always
exceptionally competent
like uh it's like used as a storytelling
tool
of like extreme competence like you know
you use it whether it's good or evil but
it's competent
it's very interesting to think about
word much more realistically
is its incompetence and that
incompetence
is in itself has uh consequences that
are difficult to uh to predict like
bureaucracy
has a very boring way of being evil
of just you know if you look at the uh
the show hbo show chernobyl
it's a really good story of how
bureaucracy
you know uh leads to
catastrophic events but not through any
kind of evil in any one
particular place but more just like the
it's just the system
kind of system distorting information as
it travels up the chain
that people unwilling to take
responsibility for things and just kind
of like this
laziness resulting in evil
you